last month over a hundred thousand
illegal aliens
were detained at the border and and it's
getting worse we're seeing in particular
more and more kids
unaccompanied kids young children kids
in cages as the media told us for for
four years relentlessly during donald
trump well there are a lot more kids in
cages right now
and the biden administration doesn't
want anyone to know this
the bride administration finally came
into the intense pressure granting
limited media access to a single holding
center
for migrant children that's happening
later today in carrizo springs texas
meanwhile senior white house officials
are set to visit mexico and guatemala
tomorrow
in a bid to stem the overwhelming surge
of migrants crossing the border
in the middle of a pandemic thomas
holman is former acting director of
immigration and customs enforcement he's
a fox news contributor it's good to have
you
um i want to listen have you listened to
another piece of sound from vice
president harris about the border
will you and the president be going down
to the border anytime soon
at some absolutely we will go down to
the board and i've been down to the
border
um and and and our secretary of the
homeland security alex mayorkas has been
down there twice
senior administration officials have
been down there and yes we will go
so there have been these visits tom but
then the visits don't translate into any
sort of change in policy at least not
yet
yeah you know they can make all the
trips to the border they want until they
undo the damaging policies of the bite
administration
things aren't going to change now that
you just mentioned together going down
mexico and guatemala meet with those
officials try to come some agreements
i like to remind them president trump
had agreements with guatemala el
salvador
honduras and mexico that they tore up
within two weeks why they would tear up
agreements with other countries that are
the source
of illegal immigration an agreement that
would help stem the flow of ill
immigration
is ridiculous they're in such a hurry
doing undoing everything trump
is that they put themselves in this
crisis and i one thing ted cruz was
exactly what he said but
i want to add one more thing what ted
cruz says yeah 100 000 a month
but there's over a thousand a day border
patrol estimates a thousand day are
getting away
because of central traffic camera
traffic drone traffic and trees that
they can't respond to because they're so
busy the family is
so there's over 30 000 that are getting
by the board patrol
in a month who are they do they have
coved are they criminals are they
carrying drugs
fentanyl on opioids that's another
that's what makes this a national
security crisis
myorkis uh what worked the border issue
for obama for
seven or eight years um he knew the plan
the policy once implemented
um what's working what's not but but
you're saying the only reason why they
changed the law
with mexico or the agreement with mexico
the only reason they changed the
agreements with central american
countries is because
donald trump had agreement with them if
that's the case
they knew what the fall on effect would
be so we've been asking people every
time they come on our air
why if you know eventually how this is
going to turn out
why do it answer that sir i wrote
i wrote an op-ed in june june of last
year eight months ago
and i said this was going to happen i
called every one of these things were
going to happen
because the promises biden was making
during the campaign
and and i've said on numerous shows this
isn't by accident this is by design
because joe biden was the vice president
in 1415 during the family search
alejandro marcus is the deputy secretary
i met with him numerous times
we talked about what causes surges and
how do we end it
how do we end it in 1415 we built
thousands of detention beds we detain
people we detained they saw a judge 90
percent lost their cases
ice removed them we took away the
enticements
what are they doing now the complete
opposite by design
they're not detaining people they're
releasing them as quick as they can
ice has been gutted they're not
deporting anyone and they keep offering
more and more enticements just like
yesterday now we're going to
process them and not give them a court
date and we'll just leave it up to them
to show up to court someday
the enticement's just keeping added
they're doing exactly the
opposite of what they know will stop
this surge that's why i said this is not
incompetence
this is not a mistake this is by design
this is what open borders look like joe
biden has sold out this country in our
national security
and our border security to win an
election there's no other excuse
and they get on tv every day and lie
about it saying it's not a crisis
but if it is a crisis of president
trump's fault president trump gave us
the most secure border my career
which spanned almost 35 years they tore
it apart in two weeks
what i would like from this
administration is a little integrity
get on national tv and tell the truth to
the american people they know the truth
is
and it's almost embarrassing to hear
them deny it then try to try to flip it
over to president trump
who gave us the most secure border i've
ever seen
tom holman look forward to hearing what
you have to say after the press
conference tomorrow because no doubt
this is going to come up
thank you